your dallas cowboys in the news
attempting to unload veteran pass rusher
everson griffin and they have according
to nfl media griffin goes to the lions
for a conditional sixth round pick
doesn't seem like much but
the cowboys unload the balance of his
salary there's a combination of salary
and significant per game roster bonuses
for everson griffin that now becomes the
obligation of the lions who are three
and three
very much alive in the nfc especially
with seven teams oh and by the way once
he gets through the covet protocols he
surely won't be able to play this
weekend game one
for
everson griffin he goes back to
minnesota as a member of the detroit
lions so makes for an interesting couple
of weeks and griffin who had two and a
half sacks so far this year for the
cowboys has a chance to make a
difference for alliance team that is
surprisingly contending
i
mike i just can't wrap my head around
this and really figure out what the
cowboys are doing i mean they didn't get
much for everson griffin he was second
on the team and sachs with two and a
half had one on sunday and played
significant staff played for 34 snaps on
sunday against washington and actually
probably his his best game but maybe
they were showcasing him to trade him i
know randy gregory's coming back but can
you count on randy gregory he played six
snaps i think the other day but can you
count on him when you haven't been able
to count on him his entire career and
you haven't seen him play in more than a
year i i just
i'm really having difficulty figuring
out what the cowboys are doing but it
almost reads like they've realized that
this year is going to be a write-off
they're not going to get it done
let's get all the cap space we can
possibly get to carry over for next year
when we can try to rebuild this defense
which is going to be the main uh thing
they're going to try to do obviously
outside of signing dak prescott to a
long-term deal
or
i'm not ready to say it's a full-blown
fire sale but to the extent you can go
player by player if you can identify a
guy that you think you can do without
that you can think doesn't fit that you
can think for whatever reason is not a
guy that is going to contribute
significantly to what it is they're
trying to do and they're still trying to
win the nfc east they're only a half
game behind the eagles with philadelphia
coming up on sunday night if griffin if
griffin is a guy they've identified
as someone they don't need yeah there's
a way to get a little something from a
contender a better contender than the
cowboys and
avoid that three million dollars six
million dollars actually in total
potential cap space that would have been
tied up this year bump it over to next
year and that's the thing under the
current cba and it's been this way for
about a decade now you can automatically
carry over any and all cap space you
want you don't have to have any tricks
you don't have to have any special
language and contracts it just carries
over and they're going to need to carry
over as much as they can so i don't look
at it as folding tents i look at look at
it as
this is a guy we can do without and we'd
rather have the six million next year
than him for the rest of this year i
don't think this is the beginning of a
sell-off i just think this is an example
of one guy and it may only be one guy
that they've decided they can do without
they'd rather have the cap space next
year
yeah i'm not sure it's a fire sell mike
but but i do think they'll listen to
offers to any and all players that they
have on their roster just to try to get
a that cap space and be whatever draft
picks they can get i do think they see
there is a significant upgrade that's
needed here especially on the defensive
side of the ball this is not a good team
it's not going to be a good team without
dak prescott and then without andy
dalton for this week or however long
he's out for sure but it's not a good
team right now so you do start thinking
about the future a little bit and maybe
it is something where another player or
two is traded i know they're going to
listen whether they get any offers that
they can't resist we'll see
this one may sound crazy and there's a
good chance that it is and i need to
look at what the cap consequences would
be what if somebody called with an offer
for zeke
i i if i'm the cowboys i unload him
right away i say bye he has not been
good not lived up to that contract i
move on from him absolutely they they
would love to get rid of that contract i
i mean it's an albatross on him right
now with with what he's doing compared
to what they're paying him it's he's
just not been good in fact he's probably
been compared to what he makes probably
the worst player on the roster so far
this season
and it looks like the cap charge next
year if they moved on from him would be
14.9
million
his cap number next year is 13.7 million
so it's not like it's going to solve
their cap issues it would solve some
cash issues
but
i don't know that anyone out there wants
to take on that contract right now
either
because
unless you are a team that otherwise has
everything else and you're
one running back away from contending
boy he could be this year's herschel
walker if there was only a dumb
franchise out there like the vikings in
1989 where's mike give up
yeah where's mike lynn when you need him
where's a team that is contending and
otherwise has every piece except a
high-end running back and would do
something like this that's not going to
happen i think that they won't get any
calls on ezekiel but at least it's
something fun to think about and yeah
look here's the thing
whatever attachment fans may have to a
player it is a
position by position name by name rip
the last name off the jersey and make a
decision about whether or not this guy
fits what you're doing what are your
alternatives what can you get and more
importantly what can you unload by way
of cap space for next year to give
yourself more room to sign dak prescott
and otherwise do business all right
jerry jones appearing as he does twice
per week although i wonder how much
longer
this is going to last i wonder he's
going to do the 60 minutes walk out on
105.3 the fan in dallas he's on there
twice a week he was on today with sean
and rj a show that i have been on from
time to time in the past
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports